dreg what's her first headline our first
headline is a halloween-themed tear
Shaun White the Olympian was forced to
apologize this week to the Special
Olympics community after dressing up as
simple Jack which is a character from
the movie Tropic Thunder mentally
handicapped character he apologized for
being offensive said it was a
last-minute decision and it was the
wrong one no way it was Lessman decision
he's been thinking about that for an
entire year it's a complicated costume
simple Jack if you haven't seen the
movie the famous expression we're not
gonna we're not going to try to offend
anyone but they have a conversation in
the movie about how you never go full
retard you want to be partially mentally
retarded in movies you'll get an Oscar
that way when you go full retard you're
you're sitting at home at Oscar night
and this is coming from a guy Robert
Downey jr. who is head to toe in
blackface so Shaun White picked a movie
where a character is in blackface the
entire time and picked the more
offensive character to portray and he's
like proud of it he's like bragging
about on Instagram my favorite part
about this is why did he apologize to
these special olympics like I can
imagine me like I'm sorry to anyone I
offended if you if you have a mentally
handicapped child or mentally
handicapped yourself and this upset you
I apologize to you but when I was going
to the organization of Special Olympics
as if they had something to do with the
movie as if it was like as if it was a
good character rights thing or is it the
Special Olympics would ever cut him off
and be like hey Shaun no thanks we saw
your Halloween costume last year we're
gonna let someone else play in the snow
with these kids who were trying to strap
a board to their feet they're lucky he
hangs out at all he didn't owe them an
apology
he should they should apologize to him
for not helping with his costume well
they made a statement saying that they
were disappointed and even even back
when the Tropic Thunder well they said
they were disappointed when in the
history of the Special Olympics and I'm
sure it's long and varied had they not
been at least vaguely disappointed do
you know what I mean like they're
they're an organization based on
disappointment i I just can't believe
you know Shaun White wasn't the guy to
kind of
Blayne like the comedic complexity going
on and in simple Jack that it was really
kind of poking fun had self-important
actors who you know play mentally
handicapped people you know cuz it just
seemed like he would he would have had
that down the only way someone would
come out on top is if he had gone like
I'm buh buh buh buh buh buh buh very
sorry like that would have been amazing
listen Eric I know you've been going
through a breakup you've been a little
sad so we have this next story just for
you this guy Greg all right Chris Sale
World Series champion three outs got the
final three for the Red Sox but his dad
sort of became a viral sensation after
there was a video taken of his dad
shirtless swinging his shirt around
during the ninth inning as his son was
winning the World Series which just kind
of got me thinking like what's the most
embarrassing thing you're your dad or
your parents have done see her he
doesn't make you feel better yeah that
story like Chris sales if Chris Dale can
still love his dad after his dad
embarrassed him like that
someone could still love you when
they're maybe like not anytime soon like
when you're in that breakup zone like
you're kind of unlovable for six months
to a year I think that you're kind of
closed off yeah definitely while you're
on this juice cleanse nothing's
happening yeah yeah I would get if I
were you I would get a cat like a pet
that would only live for six months so
they do find someone again you don't
you're not burden but yeah I thought
that would help you out mine I guarantee
my parents most of my dad's most
embarrassing stories better and this is
not the most like I would never throw my
dad under the bus
my mom under the bus even though I could
and I will once they're dead and I write
a book wait wait for that rest of the
family everyone's waiting for the
Anthony's parents gets on buck oh
my god the if you would imagine what it
took to make me imagine how many
mistakes you had to make along the way
imagine how many books you had to not
read about how to raise a kid to get me
this is my favorite I went to Montessori
School I was the oldest of five kids and
at one point in Montessori School it was
myself and two sisters in school so
three kids out of a school of let's say
like a class of like there are a hundred
kids in the school at different levels
and they have an end-of-the-year
like banquets like an end of the year
like celebration there's cake and juice
and stuff and parents are meeting
teachers and stuff and my dad gets the
job of doing a slideshow of all of the
students of like a recap of the year and
parents and teachers give my dad
pictures from all these different
students so everyone can be represented
and they start the slideshow turn the
lights off and the first picture is me
just like running everyone's kind of gah
the second picture is one of my sisters
the third picture is a different sister
the fourth picture is like three of us
together and I swear to God
95 96 percent of the pictures of a
hundred slideshow how many people are
watching everyone everyone is watching
it like it is hundreds because it's like
a hundred kids and then all of their
parents you would have thought if you
had just walked in you would have
thought this was like a tribute to three
children who had died that year in the
school it was so unbelievable at the
time I didn't understand but I've been
told later how what a humiliating
experience that was for my mother and
then everyone was very upset with my dad
and my dad's excuse was I just took the
best pictures like I just took like the
best ones aesthetically and they just
happened to be my kids but it was a like
the balls to be like yeah I'll do the
slideshow for the school and then only
put three of his kids into it it does
say a lot though of how you came out
because I think your dad just you know
believed in in his heart here the here
are the best looking badasses in the
school yeah if you were like hey dad
like he raised he raised a family of
people who just believe no matter what
that they're the best looking and
they're the best oh no I think now
everyone knows that it's that's I'm the
best one like it's all been kind of like
I'm honored Schwarzenegger and they're
all Danny DeVito you know I mean like
tied together but if you ask my dad like
if I were like a mister Jeselnik who's
better-looking Anthony or GRU you
wouldn't even get to the egg okay he
wouldn't even waffle he knows the answer
you